Terry and Meghan Markle The Duchess of
Sussex they say that aggressive
photographers cost quota near
catastrophic car chase after their
appearance here in New York City on
Tuesday night Megan was being honored no
one was hurt in this incident and police
tell us the encounter was not as serious
as Harry and Megan are making it sound
police are investigating exactly what
happened when the royal couple left the
theater you see behind me and was
surrounded by Paparazzi and chased
around the city but police sources tell
CBS news that the couple was not in
danger at that time although two NYPD
officers could have been injured I see
three people coming out of their black
SUV hop into my cab at one point the
couple joined by Megan's mother
attempted to lose photogs by jumping
into suchon Singh's Yellow Taxi
Paparazzi just came out of nowhere
taking pictures you know standing in
front of the cab and all that